but uh uh are
are men being kind of uh uh you know
pansified a little bit like are they
being
you know sold as you know men are weak
is that kind of a campaign that you're
seeing because i
have a couple guys that i work with i
have a friend of mine i had a
conversation with them over the weekend
probably
a good 90-minute conversation when my
son was doing basketball practice on
sunday
i had this conversation with this friend
of mine and i recommended him a few
years ago
a book and the reason why i recommended
him this i mean i don't know how we got
to this topic but i think it's a
conversation we need to have i'm curious
to know what a man's man's going to say
about this
so you know i noticed every time we go
out
he was so uncomfortable and on the edge
around his wife
it was like this guy couldn't enjoy
himself oh my gosh
oh my gosh oh my gosh all this other
stuff right now one day i'm
sitting there talking to him let me ask
you a question who do you spend more
time with mom or dad mom are you mama's
boy my mom is okay cool you know it's
great mama's boys it's phenomenal
i had a great laugh with my mom the
other day uh where somebody from armenia
called my band my mom from the middle
east bakwa or zarbaja called my mom and
said do you know who your son is
do you know what your son said about the
armenian community give us your son's
number we want to call him and
congratulate him
my mom's like you want me to give you my
son's number he says he says
my son barely has time to talk to him
his own family you think he's going to
call
you just we had a good laugh together
but uh
so you know we're sitting on listen tell
me about your relationship
why are you the way you are you're so on
uh walking on excellence all the time
so i said read this book which by the
way i highly recommend this book for any
man
it's called no more mr nice guy okay and
his book
explains how men used to be raised being
around their fathers more working on the
farm
so kind of like somebody like your dad
that would push him around toughen them
up all that other stuff
and after generation boys were raised
spending more time around moms than they
were around their
fathers and they got a little bit softer
to where now
men are not as strong as manly as they
once used to be now this is what the
author talks about
phenomenal book no more mr nice guy i
recommend
every nice guy to read no more mr nice
guy for many different reasons
do you think there's any credence to men
being a little bit soft nowadays
jeez don't get them started here oh my
gosh
be gentle because we don't want to
offend our nice guys please
no you know people tell me i'm a nice
guy
you know like this guy who took down
pablo just a nice one guy
who doesn't think you are i saw a photo
of him floated
barefoot you know
honestly i grew up a mama's boy because
it was easier to get things from my mom
and it was my dad
right i've always considered myself a
mama's boy but
i don't think that makes you weaker you
know and i don't see anything wrong with
being a mama's boy that's
i'm a huge on on the quality of the
sexes if you're doing the same amount of
work you deserve the same amount of pay
you deserve the same amount of recommend
recognition um
did you ever get an answer from the guy
why he was yeah did he nervous around
his wife oh he wrote the book oh yeah
he read the book and and and things
changed in their relationship
and uh uh but you know again i see a lot
of people that try to appease and
conform
way too much uh and they try to please
everybody in their lives all the time
and sometimes when you do that you're
not able to enjoy your
the things that you want to do in your
life because you're always worried about
what about what this
what about that person things now
there's a different story between
wanting to make your parents proud i
want to make my mom and dad proud
there's nothing wrong with that i want
to make sure my mom
you know looks up and says that's my son
i'm proud to have a sunlight there's
nothing wrong with that
but the part about like for example in
the middle eastern community by the way
the author's name is robert glover i'm
telling you
i highly recommend this book i've never
met the author
i've read the book multiple times he
owes you a thank you today
and just so everybody knows this is a
robert can you put the can you put the
picture up here just so we can give this
guy a shout out
and and you know what if anybody knows
robert glover and if robert glover
anybody sends this podcast to you
send him send us a message maybe we'll
bring you on here to say
to get you to talk some smackdown how
did you read it for the first time did
you think you were being too nice
no not at all so i so i had i was
reading a book called the way of man by
an author that's a very weird author
remember this guy
he came over here we interviewed him
he's a gay republican okay and he was
he's not anymore he was at the time and
he kind of changed and the interview was
a little bit awkward so you know at the
end of the interview he says well you
know i kind of wish this interview can
we cut this can we cut that camera
listen we don't do cuts we just give the
interview and i said let's just sit on
the interview we never went live with
the interview right
but when i read the book the way of man
it recommended no moments for nice guys
so i just said let me go buy all these
books because i'm leading the
organization with a lot of agents
some of them were going through this we
started recommending this book
and it changed for some people but going
back to
going back to the question of uh normal
mr nice guy
i don't know i just see a lot of people
nowadays that are constantly
trying to please everybody all the time
everybody all the time and there's an
element of when you're trying to please
everybody all the time you cannot spread
your wings
you know at some point you're gonna my
mom and dad would fight
and my dad i'll never forget what my dad
would say to my mom
my mom my dad would say why are you so
why are you like this with this
these kids you realize they're gonna do
the same thing we did and she says what
do you mean
i said your kids are gonna grow up one
day just like you left your mom and dad
to go build your own family one day
they're gonna leave you
and go build their own family they got
to be independent right so my dad was a
little bit trying to build independence
she was more trying to
build you know attachment and stick
around and all that other stuff it's
very common in the middle eastern
community
middle eastern marriages let me give you
an idea how middle eastern marriages
work
maybe a little bit closer to latino and
you guys can
can completely say it's also similar an
american type of marriage but let me
give you middle eastern marriage so say
a boy a man
decides to get married and they're
armenian
okay but the guy's armenian the girl is
mom and dad both sides very much
involved
there's a lot of politics one side will
say he shouldn't be doing this
the other side will say she shouldn't be
doing this it's so much you should raise
your kids this way you guys shouldn't do
that all this [ __ ]
should should constantly what you should
be doing and
what it typically ends up doing is the
the two that got married they loved each
other they're crazy about each other i
mean if you said
yes i do you love this woman or this man
at one point right
what caused this division between a
husband and wife these are good friends
of mine what caused the division between
the husband and wife
family's getting involved almost nine
out of ten times his family is poking
the girl
and poking the guy and saying you yeah
you should do this
and sometimes the man's like oh my gosh
yes mom you're right yes mom so mom
becomes a priority over the wife
you know when i got married i told my
mom a very interesting thing i don't
know if i told you the story the day i
got married
so i'm getting married i sent my mom
then i said for the last 30 years
you've been the number one woman of my
life effective june 26th you're gonna be
number two
so you had an official meeting with your
mom telling her the rain
is over you know what i said here's what
i said you cannot say
anything about our family and how we
want to raise our kids
unless if you want to pay for it and if
you want to raise them if you're not
going to pay for it you're not going to
raise them
we're going to raise our kids the way we
want to raise them and you may disagree
with that it's totally fine
but that's how we're going to raise our
kids she sat there at first it wasn't
because this is not an
armenian thing to do for a son to say
something like this
but we live in america and we moved on
and it's great you know family is good
it's probably important you set the tone
right yeah so to me some when i say no
more mr nice guy i
listen kai is a mama's boy i freaking
love it but kai's also a man's man
because his dad's a tough guy
okay he said he he he talks he's such a
family guy
he'll sit there in his cubicle he's
speaking in his norwegian language which
i think half the time they're talking
[ __ ] about us but you know
and then they'll start talking and all
this stuff and he'll just come in the
middle of a meeting he says hey my mom
wants to say hi
and his mom's very talkative if you're
watching i love talking to you but you
can talk
and so all of a sudden she'll go 45
minutes her an hour talking but you know
what
as much as kai is close to his family
he's going to go to spend time with his
family for a couple weeks
the guy's still a man's man he still has
that independence so
i think that mixture of having both is
so necessary
sometimes when you get too much of it on
one side with men they become too nice
and you know they don't spread their
wings what are your thoughts tom about
this you know what i want to read that
book
shonda don't get upset if he reads this
oh my god
shonda's gonna say screw that book oh
she'll burn it i mean
i might get a little liberation i mean
it'll be like a coup
in the house a say in something you know
what you talk about a five foot two
dictator man i mean she
but it's all good um how do you get that
book
amazon you you will
i'm being sincere with everybody yeah i
highly recommend that book
i don't make a penny off this guy i've
never met the author i have no idea who
he is
but it's a phenomenal book for anybody
to read so do you have any other
opinions on that with the
men that are sometimes too soft or no no
not really yeah
you know everybody's set your own
standards you are a nice guy live up to
your stream you know what steve you're a
nice guy i don't care what pablo said
about you i think you're a nice guy